[Musique]
on saura tout ce mercredi 28 novembre
bienvenue dans le 7-8 journal de tv 78
si vous nous rejoignez à 18 heures nous
sommes depuis le cinéma ugc skywest pour
le ouverture du festival à saint quentin
tout de suite les titres de cette
édition c'est le festival du film
documentaire organisé par tv 78 saint
quentin est lancé ce soit une quatrième
édition dédiée à l'espace huit films
sont en compétition officielle au
programme de l'événement des projections
des grands classiques des soirées
spéciales et des animations ont fait le
point avec nos invités laurent mazaury
marque alban grave et armelle rigaud
l'informatique du futur se préparera aux
clayes-sous-bois le groupe atos
construit dans la ville son laboratoire
mondial de recherche et de développement
est la première pierre de l'édifice a
été posée hier en présence de la
présidente de région valérie pécresse
et puis retour sur le séminaire du
circuit court qui s'est tenue samedi
dernier à villepreux l'ensemble des
acteurs agriculteurs et associations du
territoire
il était représenté à
saint-quentin-en-yvelines 32
exploitation interviennent sur près de
21% des espaces agricoles
à suivre également dans ce journal
interview de didier fischer candidat
sans étiquette pour l'élection
municipale partielle à coignières second
tour ce dimanche dans la commune
c'est l'événement du film documentaire à
saint quentin en yvelines le festival
saint quentin s'ouvre ce soir depuis le
lieu où nous nous trouvons l'ugc skywest
jusqu'au 2 décembre huit films en
compétition officielle des projections
et animations sur tout le territoire de
l'agglomération alors pour en parler en
plateau trois invités mark allemand
grave s bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes le
directeur de l'ugc skywest membre du
jury du festival également merci de nous
accueillir pour ce jt spécial et pour
cette soirée d'ouverture nous avons
également armé le rigodon soir alors
vous êtes responsable de l'action des
manifestations culturelles et
scientifiques pour les bibliothèques
universitaires de l'université
versailles saint quentin en yvelines on
parlera notamment avec vous du programme
autour du festival il ya des choses qui
sont organisées notamment la b u
à guyancourt et bonsoir laurent mazaury
bonsoir vous êtes le président tv soit
118 on va commencer cette interview avec
vous quatrième édition de ce festival
saint quentin pourquoi tv 78 organise un
festival du film documentaire
alors on est dans la lignée de
l'engagement de la chaîne en tout ce qui
concerne la propagation des images est
plus positive et d'utilisation de la
télévision est entre autres le
sponsoring que nous avons toujours voulu
donner les chances au documentaire c'est
aujourd'hui un arrêt en même temps un
mode de communication qui a retrouvé ses
lettres de noblesse et je crois que les
télévisions locales et autres autres tv
soixante dix huit doivent propager et
positivement montrer tout ce que le
documentaire peut apporter à la fois en
termes de connaissance de plaisir parce
que je pense que l'on peut montrer dans
les documentaires qu'on peut lui prendre
du plaisir c'est pas rébarbative bien au
contraire c'est grand public et dans ce
sens-là de la télévision des yvelines
que nous sommes aujourd'hui se doit
d'être un des éléments moteurs et de
promotion des documentaires alors il ya
eu comme thème dans les années
précédentes l'environnement le sport la
musique cette année c'est l'espace c'est
pas un thème anodin pour saint quentin
en yvelines
alors c'est ni intérêt ni d'un pour
saint-quentin divine ni un thème anodin
pour les yvelines
puisque nous sommes un des plus grands
départements de france dans lequel un
nombre très important de sociétés
travaillent pour l'espace de près ou de
loin puisque j'ai eu l'occasion de lire
dans d'autres endroits il ya évidemment
sur le territoire des entreprises
majeures entre au suspense airbus mais
pas qu'eux qui sont directement liés à
l'espace bien entendu on a une pensée
aussi pour toutes les entreprises qui
sont basé aux mureaux et qui travaille
dans le secteur de l'espace mais
également tout ce que nous avons autour
de nous bien souvent vient directement
de l'espace je pense à nos téléphones
aux différentes recherches qui ont peut
être mené dans le cadre aujourd'hui de
proma qui sont anciens je pense au
programme apollo pour lequel on a encore
aujourd'hui des débouchés et on le voit
cette semaine nous sommes de l'actualité
puisque nous avons une sonde de plus qui
a pu atteindre mars et on voit à chaque
fois tout ce que cela porte d'un point
de vue technologique et technique mais
également faut pas oublier d'un point de
vue philosophique car on fait également
évoluer l'esprit de l'homme grâce à la
conquête spatiale
alors c'est un festival a accueilli
films en compétition des projections de
grands classiques on va en parler dans
un instant est un festival qui ne
pourrait pas se faire sans ses
partenaires notamment l'ugc lu vs que
aussi à markham en gras baisse depuis le
début l'ugc
accompagne ce festival saint quentin
pourquoi on sait que ça fait quatre ans
maintenant qu'on accompagne je refais un
petit peu la génèse du festival c'était
avec guy barbedette qu'est le directeur
de tv 78 on avait envie de créer un lien
culturel mais aussi autres dans tout le
territoire et on se dit qu'est ce qui
peut réunir à la fois des universités
d'été des cinémas des théâtres
c'est de créer un festival autour du
cinéma du festival documentaire
pour créer un lien et voilà ça fait
maintenant la quatrième année qu'on
développe et que ce festival grandit au
fur et à mesure alors il ya trois temps
forts dans ce festival la soirée
d'ouverture qui se déroulera à partir de
19 heures 30 avec un concert autour des
musiques de science fiction aussi une
émission spéciale paf animée par patrice
carmouze
il y aura également une soirée ça va
rappeler des souvenirs temps x demain en
présence des frères bogdanoff oui on va
s'asseoir comme vous l'avez dit je sais
pas si vous le voyez là en direct qui a
déjà toutes les pupitres des musiciens
qui sont installés donc il ya une
trentaine de musique vingtaine de
minutes de musique de films qui vont
avoir lieu juste après votre émission et
lé projet la semaine prochaine demain
plutôt ont fait la soirée temps x alors
pour ceux qui sont de ma génération de
notre génération
bah voilà ça nous rappelle plein de
choses le voyage imaginaire etc
et c'est vrai qu'on a la chance
d'accueillir les frères bogdanoff demain
pour qu'ils vont nous présenter leur
documentaire et j'espère qu'il y aura un
très bel échange avec la salle après le
dernier temps fort ça ne sera pas ici
mais aussi naissait d'elancourt
puisqu'il y aura la soirée de clôture
dimanche avec les différents prix qui
seront remis quatre prix le prix tv 78
le prix 3e prix du public et prix des
des cinémas huit films en compétition
que faut-il retenir de la sélection
cette année on rappelle que vous êtes
vous êtes membre du écouter on a voulu
faire une sélection assez large mais
aussi un petit peu pointu sur le
télescope à l'intérieur sur scozzi et
ses atouts que je pense qu'on a quand
même pour tous les publics
voilà moi je vas voter mais j'invite
aussi public à voter pour leur
documentaire de coeur et puis bon on
verra que le meilleur gagne pour
dimanche prochain au ciné 7
il y aura aussi la projection de grands
classiques on parle d'eux
pardon 2001 l'odyssée de l'espace le
classique de kubrick je me tourne vers
armelle rigaud pour refermer cette
interview on donnera après on fera un
dernier tour de table après autour de
cette sélection officielle il ya des
animations qui sont organisées notamment
à la bibliothèque universitaire de
guyancourt oui oui c'est la première
fois que la bibliothèque universitaire
participe au festival du film
documentaire donc à cette occasion la
bibliothèque propose de belles
expositions réalisées conjointement avec
nos partenaires
le premier le groupe airbus puisque
c'est une exposition qui a été réalisé
avec la cité de l'espace de toulouse qui
met en lumière les femmes astronautes
depuis leur premier lancement touché
apporter une affiche donc cette première
femme russe en 1963 donc c'est une
exposition de photographies dont une
soixantaine de portraits de toutes
nationalités et puis la deuxième
exposition qui a été réalisé avec un
laboratoire de recherche de l'université
le laboratoire latmos exploration
martienne curiosity donc une donnée
collègues
après ce journal viendra présenter le
l'implication du laboratoire de
recherche latmos dans l'exploration
martienne qui est d'actualité comme vous
l'avez l'on colle avec l'actualité avec
le la mission insight qui s'est produit
hier sur martin ça c'est une autre
mission mais elle vous expliquera plus
particulièrement et donc autour de ces
deux expositions des animations donc
demain c'est le latmos qui viendra
présenter son exposition d'entre d'eux
midi à 15 heures est complété par un
laboratoire de réalité virtuelle qui
nous plongera sur la planète mars et
vous pourrez véhiculer curiosity qui est
un robot en 7 1 qui se déplace et qui
est installée depuis 2012 sur la planète
mars
et puis
voir un petit peu le paysage
extraordinaire de cette planète
toutes ces animations sont gratuites
ouvertes à tous sur seulement les
étudiants puisque la bibliothèque est
ouverte c'est un conte fussent ouvert
ouvert sur la ville et le lendemain le
vendredi une conférence qui va être
animée par trois ingénieurs de groupe
airbus qui viendra présenter ses
parcours universitaire respectifs et
surtout tous les métiers de l'ombre qui
permettent aux astronautes d'explorer
l'espace
en un mot on arrive déjà la fin de cet
entretien qui est ce qu'on lui souhaite
à ce festival saint quentin cette
quatrième édition laurent mazaury on lui
souhaite bien entendu une grande
réussite et en un mot il ya deux points
également important je voudrais
souligner le premier c'est que ce sont
les femmes dans la recherche qui sont là
et on est à une semaine après le women's
forum qui s'est déroulé à paris sous
l'égide de l'onu et de l'unesco
voyez que tv 78 aigles official est
vraiment en ligne avec son époque et
tout ce qui touche aux fins et d'équité
et le deuxième point c'est un bel
exemple également de collaboration
puisque en général on nous cite toujours
les guerres entre les multiplexes et les
cinémas locaux ou d'art et essai et on
voit là qu'on a une vraie collaboration
entre les différentes salles sur
l'agglomération ça également c'est un
point important qu'il faut mettre en
lumière vrai un mot un vrai un mot
pardon et on a dépassé le temps pour on
lui souhaite qu à ce festival non mais
je pense que voilà les gens vont
découvrir le festival le re découvrir
dès ce soir
il ya plein d'animations au cinéma ociné
7 à l'université dans le centre
commercial pour ceux qui veulent
notamment piloté un drone et puis vous
avez le programme qui distribue un peu
partout il ya plein d'animations
quasiment tout est gratuit venez en
profiter en mail rigaux idem que les
festivals apporte beaucoup de plaisir et
qui permet de susciter des vocations
pour la jeune génération
et ce dimanche ce festival pardon c'est
jusqu'à dimanche une soirée d'ouverture
à ne pas rater à partir de 19h30 avec
une émission spéciale paf animé par
laurent lampard dont patrick carmouze
patrice carmouze j'en profite d'ailleurs
pour faire un clin d'oeil à mathieu
rostaing qui a grandement travailler à
l'organisation de ce festival
ce sera le laboratoire mondial de
recherche et de développement d'atos le
groupe de services numériques a choisi
clayes-sous-bois comme site
d'implantation le pdg de l'entreprise et
la présidente de la région valérie
pécresse sont venus hier posé la
première pierre de cet édifice
il développera des projets innovants de
transformation digitale est les détails
avec nicolas d'andry le site atos des
clayes-sous-bois futur lieu de
développement des ordinateurs du futur
cette société leader international de la
transformation digitale a lancé la
construction de son laboratoire mondial
de recherches et développement
un espace de 8000 mètres carrés près de
500 ingénieurs des travaux focaliser sur
l'informatique quantique à travers le
programme
atos quantum on commence à réfléchir
alors informatique need quantique c'est
à dire utiliser un concept totalement
descriptif pour permettre aux futurs
ordinateurs de demain accéléré de façon
tout à fait considérable leur puissance
de calcul
mais c'est aussi un lieu qui nous permet
d'avoir beaucoup de compétences dans le
monde académique mais aussi parmi tous
les jeunes qui se forment
on est pas mal le plateau de saclay il
ya beaucoup de compétences la région
ile-de-france a investi 5 millions
d'euros sur ce programme de recherche
un projet au coeur des territoires de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines et de paris
saclay l'ordinateur quantique c'est
l'ordinateur du futur c'est la
technologie d'après c'est celle qui va
complètement transformer l'informatique
demain alors à tous a beaucoup hésité et
la région a considéré que c'était un
investissement totalement stratégique
nous devons avec les meilleurs dans ces
domaines c'est pour ça qu'il ne fallait
pas que le centre de recherche d'atos
partent en province et encore moins à
l'étranger et la région s'est fortement
mobilisée nous sommes très heureux
aujourd'hui de cette décision
c'est une très bonne nouvelle bien
entendu pour le tout les yvelines et
bien entendu notamment 50 en iv
qui est directement impliqué dans tous
les projets avec la qualité des
entreprises que vous avez avec 13
milliards de chiffre d'affaires atos
poursuit son ambition mondiale
ce nouveau laboratoire devrait ouvrir
courant 2020
les sénateur des yvelines en visite dans
le département en compagnie du président
du sénat l'yvelinois gérard larcher cinq
parlementaires aient l'air ont rencontré
les acteurs du territoire de saint
germain boucles de seine entreprises
mais aussi élus qui ont fait part de
leurs inquiétudes du moment des
inquiétudes dans l'exercice de la
fonctionnaire mais aussi des inquiétudes
financières avec la suppression de la
taxe d'habitation
prochaines visites prévues sur le
territoire de versailles
écoutez gérard larcher géant un peu plus
de deux mois visité 18 départements à la
rencontre des élus que je sent tendu
interrogatif parfois découragés et c'est
encore plus vrai hors de la région
ile-de-france où de grandes métropoles
et ces élus là depuis des mois nous
annonce un peu ce que nous ressentons
aujourd'hui dans le ras-le-bol fiscale
dans le ras le bol qui s'exprime de la
part d'une partie 2 le français est
français et je dois dire que il faut que
l'exécutif entendent cglu dans
l'actualité politique locale et quoi
n'ya rien sont de nouveau appelés aux
urnes ce dimanche second tour de
l'élection municipale partielle
donc ceux de ce 2 décembre par dont deux
bureaux de vote seront ouverts de 8
heures à 18 heures en mairie et à
l'école bouvet avec moi sur ce plateau
didier fischer bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes
l'un des deux candidats pour ce second
tour candidat sans étiquette tête de
liste de nouvel élan pour coignières
alors vous avez recueilli au premier
tour 513 voix 48,03 % des suffrages vous
êtes placé en tête vous êtes donc en
ballottage favorable pour ce second tour
et vous étiez à seulement une vingtaine
de voix de remporter l'élection au
premier tour ya pas eu un peu de
frustration de votre part il ya toujours
il ya toujours un petit peu de
frustration quand on est quand on est à
23 voix près c'est évident
mais bon on n'est pas déçu c'est un très
beau score on doit évidemment une
implantation de terrain depuis onze ans
on le doit aussi à une très belle
campagne que mon équipe a mené depuis
deux mois donc on est quand même
satisfait du résultat
alors c'est vrai c'est une nouvelle
élection qui débute puisque maintenant
il n'y a plus que deux listes
donc à quoi ressemblent vos journées
depuis dimanche justement comment à quoi
ressemble votre vos journées nos
journées depuis dimanche soir c'est du
porte à porte tous les soirs à l'heure
actuelle c'est des rencontres avec les
coigné rien nous allons chercher les
dernières voix qui nous manque pour
l'emporter dimanche vous serez opposé on
précise au second tour ali bousselham
qui est candidat également sans
étiquette sur la liste coignières avenir
qui a recueilli 36 % 36 30 % au premier
tour un mot sur la participation a été
de 47 % vous attendiez à moins à plus
sur moi j'espérais au moins tu
participes participation à 50% faut bien
voir que c'est une élection partielle
donc il ya toujours une participation
inférieure à une élection normale à
coignières c'était 61 % en 2014 47% donc
en 2018
c'est un peu insuffisant quand même et
vos perspectives pour dimanche le
troisième candidats qui étaient en lice
au premier tour david pelletier s'est
lui retiré pour ce second tour il avait
totalisé 15 59% des voix
quelles sont vos perspectives on va peut
parler de report de voix est ce que vous
avez peur que ces voiles vers la libye
si l'on écoutait déjà moi je salue la
décision courageuse de david pelletier
c'était pas évident et c'est même un
cercle il ya un certain panache à se
retirer et il est toujours plus
difficile d'être à l'extérieur d'un
conseil municipal qui à l'intérieur pour
faire avancer les choses
donc c'est leur stratégie à l'heure
actuelle le jeu salus ce désistement
d'une certaine façon maintenant
la perspective il est évident que dans
cette situation je pense qu' un certain
nombre de voix peut effectivement nous
revenir les zélés les listes ne sont pas
propriétaires de leurs voix d'ailleurs
david pelletier le faisait remarquer
dans son communiqué moi j'ai toujours
été quelqu'un d'ouvert qui a travaillé
avec tout le monde
donc ya pas de raison que certaines
personnes ne se reconnaissent pas non
plus en moi dans mon équipe est dans
notre projet justement votre projet pour
terminer à coignières quelles sont les
priorités selon vous pourrez les
priorités c'est déjà de revenir à la
sérénité
c'est de réhabiliter un certain nombre
d'équipements publics c'est de mettre en
place aussi d'une façon véritable un
plan de réhabilitation un plan de
maintenance aussi de ses équipements
publics
c'est aussi de réviser le p lus 1 avec
et là je voudrais lancer un appel à
l'état
nous avons là la perspective de
construire un nouveau quartier près de
la gare mais moi je ne tiens pas à
construire un deuxième coignières à côté
du premier
il nous faut absolument que l'état
comprenne qu'il faut enfouir cette
nationale 10
au moins là ménagé partiellement afin de
permettre de réunir la ville et de
construire les 450 logements que l'état
nous oblige à construire
donc voyez il ya quand même des
perspectives importantes dans les années
qui viennent ensuite il est évident
aussi je souhaite une plus grande
participation de la population et on
mettra en place des conseils de quartier
avec un budget participatif pour que les
habitants s'emparent de leur
environnement de proximité
merci didier fischer d'avoir été avec
nous je rappelle que vous êtes candidat
sans étiquette et de liste nouvel élan
pour coignières pour ce second tour de
la municipale partielle à coignières
versys si vous me permettez les impôts
j'appelle évidemment je remercie déjà
tous les électeurs qui ont apporté leurs
suffrages dimanche et j'appelle
effectivement les quoi ni rien et les
coignard yen à amplifier le mouvement
afin que ce nouvel élan pour coignet
reprennent réalité dimanche soir ils
pourront voter c'est quoi n'y a rien de
8 heures à 18 heures ce dimanche
2 décembre et je rappelle didier fischer
que vous serez opposé à ali bousselham
candidat également sans étiquette pour
la liste coignières à venir
et après ce scrutin partiel à coignières
les prochaines élections municipales en
france sont programmés dès 2020 à
elancourt le maire les républicains jean
michel fourgous sera candidat pour un
cinquième mandat il a annoncé dans les
colonnes de la gazette saint quentin en
yvelines
celui qui est également président de
l'agglomération saint-quentinoise est à
la tête de la municipalité depuis 1996
jean michel fourgous indique vouloir se
représenter car de grands projets
arrivent sur le territoire dont les jeux
olympiques 2024 dont l'épreuve de vtt se
déroulera notamment sur la colline
d'elancourt
à l'occasion de la journée
internationale de lutte contre les
violences faites aux femmes dimanche
plusieurs actions ont été menées dans
les yvelines attrape un stand de
prévention et d'information était
installée en mairie
cette semaine manon varaldo s'est rendu
sur place
une femme meurt tous les trois jours
victime de son conjoint ou ex conjoint
sur le stand de prévention et
d'information en mairie de trappes un
ruban blanc était distribué symbole de
solidarité les changes est primordial
gros parcours la première
les violences faites aux femmes sont
souvent assimilés aux coûts mais il
existe aussi la violence psychologique
la violence psychologique et une
violence morale qui est un délit pénal
aujourd'hui depuis la loi de route 2010
mais qui est très difficile à mettre en
fer qualifié par le tribunal
et donc il est nécessaire d'être
accompagné par des avions spécialisés
dont notre association
quatre victimes sur cinq ne porte pas
plainte par sentiment de culpabilité
il faut faire cesser ces violences n'est
pas quelque chose de naturel donc la
police est là pour recevoir les plaintes
mais en amont avant de prendre ma place
au politico-social nour souvent les
femmes qui évite alors qu'elles sont
victimes et non pas coupable c'est ce
sentiment sous - quel dont la subissent
des violences aient l'impression d'être
coupables et non son wiki libérer ses
mots ses blessures écrire et parfois
plus simple que de parler pour les
victimes les personnes sur le stand
pouvez rédiger un message un témoignage
et les déposer sur un arbre à meaux on
peut être soit des victimes on peut
connaître aussi où on peut être
simplement sensibiliser à cette
problématique là donc l'idée c'est de
mettre un petit mot sur cet arbre
l'arbre hameau sera exposé le jeudi 6
décembre à l'occasion de la pièce de
théâtre des coûts et du silence acrap
elle se déroulera à 20h à l'école de
musique et de danse échangé avec
l'ensemble des acteurs locaux
agriculteurs et associations type amap
le but du séminaire organisé samedi
dernier au domaine de grand'maisons à
villepreux moment de dialogue important
dans le cadre de la mise en place est
d'un plan d'action pour le développement
de l'agriculture locale et des circuits
courts les précisions de manon varaldo
et de nicolas landry le territoire de
saint quentin en yvelines est composé à
21% des espaces agricoles à l'occasion
du séminaire du manger local une
convention annuelle d'objectifs a été
signé on est sur un objectif de
pérenniser
l'agriculture qui existe déjà sur le
territoire de l'aider à une
transformation vers plus de local de
conversion aussi vers beaucoup plus de
respect en terme environnemental et
aussi donc
quand c'est possible de pouvoir
favoriser les installations pour une
diversification 32 exploitation agricole
interviennent sur le territoire de saint
quentin en yvelines
mais certains agriculteurs sont entier
espère beaucoup de ce séminaire en
présence des acteurs locaux
on vit dans une région où on voit leur
bannissement prendre du terrain agricole
mais a contrario nous on a du mal à
faire nos bâtiments
je veux de la sérénité et de la
confiance parce qu'on n'est pas là pour
tout juste d'être là deux ans et demi
trois ans et puis après faire autre
chose vous laisser en abandon cetc des
projets de vie qu'on met en place et ça
alors faire comprendre aux acteurs
locaux c'est je m'aperçois c'est très
compliqué clément produit une
cinquantaine de paniers pour la map
local 100% villepreux qui a pour
vocation de soutenir l'installation des
agriculteurs dans leurs activités
on a plus de 115 119 famille qui est qui
et qui viennent qui se fournissent par
ce biais là tantôt comment à dire sous
forme de contrats hebdomadaire tantôt
sous forme de contrats bimensuel les
amap association pour le maintien d'une
agriculture paysanne permettent une
vente directe sans intermédiaire entre
le producteur et le consommateur 100% du
montant du panier est reversée aux
paysans pour terminer ce journal durant
une semaine le réseau des médiathèques
de saint quentin en yvelines vous a fait
jouer dans toute l'agglomération cette
semaine du jeu se terminait se terminait
dimanche à la commanderie des templiers
la commanderie pardon à elancourt au
programme murder party escape game et
jeux de société marylène iapichino est
entré dans la partie
un meurtre a été commis dans l'espace
exposition de la commanderie
les participants deux heures pour
récolter des indices et interroger les
comédiens on a vu son assistant qui nous
a dit que c'était pas ça
non c'est pas la signature de mon père
les équipes fouille les moindres recoins
pour mener l enquête dans ce plu et de
grandeur nature j'ai trouvé un
antisioniste siège et c'est à moi et
l'interview pour l'instant autre salle
autre ambiance pour ceux qui préfèrent
les skates games à la murder party
ici il faut résoudre des énigmes pour
trouver le plan d'une invention
révolutionnaire et le livrer en temps et
en heure
le fait de tout ce s'éparpiller puis
deux à chaque fois communiquer les uns
les autres à nous à permis quand même 2
bat aller au bout de l'expérience mais
c'est vraiment très bien pour les plus
traditionnels la commanderie proposait
également un espace jeux de société aux
règles parfois compliqué il faut trouver
l'objet la forme correspondante
et ensuite si c'est pas le cas il faut
prendre celle qui n'existe pas en fait
une journée rythmée pour tous les âges
une façon de mettre en avant le travail
des médiathèques autour du jeu on sent
un véritable engouement de la part
d'aidé publique et des habitants pour
pour venir jouer pour venir jouer en
famille et dans une ambiance toujours
très
calme sereine et
et détendue et ça fait du bien cette
journée de jeu à la commanderie
affichait presque complet
une bonne façon de clôturer la semaine
du jeu de saint quentin en yvelines
avant de préparer sa prochaine édition
avant de se quitter je vous rappelle ce
rendez vous ce soir la soirée et
d'ouverture du festival saint quentin à
suivre en direct sur tv 78 dès 19h30
en première partie concert de musique de
science fiction par l'harmonie de saint
quentin en yvelines
patrice carmouze prendra ensuite le
relais pour une édition spéciale de son
émission paf
il sera entouré des chercheurs nathalie
à carrasco et caroline freyssinet de
pascal picq et 2 françois-xavier bellamy
la quatrième édition de ce festival
saint quentin c'est jusqu'à dimanche
soirée de clôture au prisme d'elancourt
aussi les sept d'elancourt pardon huit
films documentaires sur le thème de
l'espace sont en compétition
voilà c'est la fin de ce set 8 journal
depuis le cinéma ugc skywest où l'on le
se retrouvera également à demain jeudi
pour une nouvelle édition belle soirée
avec tv 78
[Musique]